a Big Mac hat and a cat Bunny salad it's
episode 45 of IMG this tent was pitched
high up above the clouds the snow and
clouds make it look like a sky tent but
can you find what's hiding in these
leaves make your Snuggie super by
looking like spider-man Batman or Wonder
Woman these double pupils are Photoshop
but have you ever noticed that sonic has
it too his eyes are conjoined they're
like one big giant white ball in his
head with two pupils perfectly time
photos.com has some neato shots
lightning on water head touching water
cat not yet touching water and a
ping-pong ball you're never too old to
play and now some unfortunately placed
price tags enjoy
you
Tyree Callahan invented this color
typewriter the keys use pastels to
generate art and this poor seal was
abandoned by all the other seals because
he was born a ginger wetsuits are fun
and so are baby dolphins but let's get
cuter this dog is getting a bear hug not
enough how about a chimpanzee feeding a
tiger cub or Tigers licky better yet
this guy who no kidding actually stole a
photographer's camera and snapped these
photos of himself
now all these animal images were on
BuzzFeed's list a sight we're typing the
Konami code rewards you it kind of by
the way you can still play pac-man on
Google by going to google.com slash
pac-man and this product is not
available yet but it's genius hamburger
wrapping paper stack gifts to make
custom burgers if you have expensive
tastes try these name brand cereal
concepts artist Tim Schneider makes the
world a better place by putting big old
eyeballs on things and this road in
Norway looks like it goes nowhere but
actually it's just an oddly curved
bridge now let's learn daily infographic
calm is sweet here's a history of the
word geek from the words origins in the
1500s as gekkan meaning a fool to the
middle period when it meant someone
obsessed with technology or a certain
subculture to the modern geek chic
meaning where a geek or Gleek is a
revered title and how about this one
covering the chemicals your skin takes
in your skin absorbs 60% of every
topical product you put on it
furthermore in her lifetime the average
girl will involuntarily eat 4 pounds of
lipstick on the subject of infographics
and charts and graphs take a look at
this it's an illustration of the Turkish
Empire's reach made in 1801 by William
Playfair and it was the very first pie
chart ever drawn by humans on Monday I
tweeted my excitement for owning this
book because shadows are magic like
these two strangers who passed by each
other though their shadows told a
different story
I also tweeted disillusioned
demonstrating a Troxler Spain blurry or
faint colors will disappear from your
periphery if you stare long enough
finally I shot a gun for the first time
in my life Destin was there with me and
he has this excellent scientific method
for recording muzzle flash and the
shooter you go from this to this he's
gonna have a video soon where he
explains the entire process and how we
made the photos happen but in the
meantime check out this video of the
very moment I fired a gun for the first
time that felt pretty good
and as always thanks for watching